okay this week league of legends changed
forever riot games released a patch
which many people are saying is the
biggest one the game has ever seen every
single champion has been affected why
did they do this and what exactly are
they changing i'm going to sum it all up
for you right now
[Music]
all right we've got a lot to talk about
in today's video this patch is also
going to affect the game for a long time
to come which we will be talking about
most likely in the future so if you
don't want to miss those videos make
sure you subscribe to the channel and if
you enjoy this one leave a like on your
way out the door cheers all right so if
you played league years ago and then
recently came back to the game there's
probably a lot of things that you'd
notice were different there's been
changes to the map new dragons new
champions new items new mechanics you
get the idea but one thing that a lot of
returning players notice and something
that continuous players have been
complaining about for years is damage
creep to put it simply a lot of
champions reached a point where they
could deal a lot of damage without much
of a trade-off sometimes they didn't
even have to land their own skill shots
see what i'm saying
too much damage in the game he misses
ulti his e he missed literally every
ability possible and i died
and i exhausted him not only that but it
also restricted champion diversity in a
game where certain champions are able to
just delete people with relative ease
why pick anything else there's a lot of
champions out there that offer things
other than damage but their qualities
have become increasingly irrelevant by
comparison and their pick rate has
plummeted as a result now if you're
relatively new to the game this might be
all you've ever known but some players
have been pulling up clips from past
seasons to show just how out of hand
things have gotten look here stark's
black cleaver with the same items i
would be sold at immediately
but look he's dealing no damage
what is this
look at the damage
zero
it is crazy
how much damage there is in the game now
compared to old seasons it is crazy but
after years of crying rito please about
damage creep they finally listened patch
12.10 which went live this week is
called the champion durability update it
promises to increase durability across
the board all champions have received 70
more health 14 more health growth 1.2
more armor growth and 0.8 more magic
resist growth now you'll notice here
that riot have opted to make all
champions more tanky instead of nerfing
damage across the board that might seem
like a trivial difference they both
result in less damage overall but some
players like doublelift have theorized
that riot's decision might be a
psychological one losing something such
as damage feels way worse actually twice
feels twice as bad as gaining something
feels good and and so it's a
psychological thing where real like at
the end of the day it doesn't really
matter what they do they could increase
durability or decrease damage what
you're really doing is you're making hp
bars go down slower okay that's what the
that's what the purpose of this change
is but before we get all carried away
here let's not forget the damage in its
healthy form is a good thing it's the
stuff of highlight reels it feels good
to deal it out it's not inherently bad
riot reassured everyone in a blog post
earlier this month that they aren't
trying to create games with no kills at
50 minutes they acknowledge that high
damage and the low survivability that
comes with it can lead to more exciting
pro matters and that it feels good for
players to kill enemies instead of just
forcing them to recall but they were
clear in their belief that increasing
champions defensive stats will be
beneficial for letting players showcase
their skill by giving them more
opportunities for counterplay and to
live out their high moments now living
out your high moments might sound like
something your auntie would post on
facebook but there is some sense to it
riot are essentially trying to stretch
out fights for longer whether they're
1v1s in lane or full-on objective
teamfights they want players to
experience these moments for longer and
have more opportunities to react to
incoming damage something that's
definitely been lacking at times
what
the patch notes also outline how riot
will be nerfing heels and shields in
order to balance out the increased
durability a total of 93 champions have
had their heels and shields cut down yes
even alistar couldn't escape then of
course we've got summoner spells such as
barrier and heel soul buffs such as
mountain drake's shield and ocean
drake's heal and items like shield bow
redemption and the bane of my existence
gore drinker seriously there was a while
back there where i almost quit the game
because of kane players building gore
drinker actual anti-fun now all of this
makes sense because heels and shields
become exponentially more powerful as a
team fight goes on trust me as a former
ivan mane myself you can see his picture
right there on my wall i knew that if my
teammates didn't die in the first few
seconds of a team fight i could keep
them alive with a few shield rotations
unfortunately for ivan it's not looking
too good for him this patch ivor an
eshield so this is one that i was
concerned about um let's take a look at
how bad it is wow it's bad
so the obvious question now is what will
the game be like now how will the meta
shift clearly assassins and mages are no
longer going to be able to have their
cake and eat it all round tankier
champions means they're less able to
just delete people with ease and already
some assassin players aren't too happy
about the situation
where is my damage
riot
where is it
on the other side of the coin you've got
80 carry mains who are frankly shocked
that they're actually able to play the
game now without their screen being
perma gray
and the way i'm able to play like this
is not like
like is this not insane guys can you see
this
like this is actually how league of
legends used to be they can't just uh
one shot you
and then you can just outplay them like
look at this
and it's not just squishy 80 carries
that are feeling pretty blessed right
now bruisers are likely to be very happy
with the changes too they'll certainly
benefit from the drawn out team fights
and really any champion that takes a
while to scale will see this as a
positive change of course that means any
champions who can directly counter those
who are benefiting from all of this will
also benefit from it more tankiness for
everyone means that true or percentage
damage dealers like vayne are gonna have
an absolute field day it's the patch
circle of life and it really does move
through us all high burst assassins or
mages are obviously going to take a hit
but those who could offer some utilities
such as victor or azir may survive the
purge or even thrive one final thing i
want to touch on is that baron nasha is
getting tougher he'll have more damage
across the board including both his
attack and magic damage he'll be a more
formidable objective all round not just
something you can two man sneak at 20
minutes anymore personally i like this
change and it ties in well with that
shift towards more drawn out team fights
that riot really seems to be pushing for
turrets are getting tougher too so
between that and baron and champions not
getting deleted anymore the game really
might feel like old league to some
players are these changes good i think
so overall although obviously it's early
days and it depends on what you play as
for pro play we're gonna have to wait
until after msi to see how pro teams
adapt but one thing is for sure the game
is going to be noticeably different at
the highest level let me know what you
think of the new patch what has been
your best and worst experience so far
i'm probably going to go and play a few
games of ivan right now he might still
be absolutely crap but
my god i still love him
let me read out a few ivan quotes
what a wonderful day
gooseberries would love it
laugh like a hyena and friends will
gallop to your side
such great quotes this is just these 30
quotes and they're all bangers